what's your experience with piracy and
IMDB ratings piracy is inevitable as
soon as soon as your movie comes out it
will be pirated what's interesting about
the piracy in relation to the ratings is
that it's the most somehow it's the
people who don't pay for your movie who
feel kind of most entitled to to go out
watch one minute of it that they you
know torrented and then go on IMDb and
and write a review I only watched one
minute of this I'm gonna give it one
star it's the worst movie I've ever seen
and um part of it is that they just are
expecting that they think every movie is
basically like 100 million dollar movie
they don't understand like what an
independent movie is because from their
perspective they're just they're going
on the torrent site and they're like oh
here's a list of new things I'll just
grab the you know all these things and
they turn it on for a minute and it
doesn't look like what they expect they
don't know that they're seeing an
independent film and so you get waves
and waves it's it's really uh as soon as
that piracy happens you start getting
waves and waves waves of negative
comments and negative ratings in IMDb
and one of the ways you can tell this
is that like for example we had a movie
that was only released in the US only
available on limited Platforms in the US
and uh the you know the day it goes up
on on Pirate Bay uh you start getting
all these comments from other countries
the only way they could have watched it
is basically through piracy and once in
a while I've gone in and like commented
back or confronted them in places where
I say you know clearly you you pirated
this movie because like you're you live
in Brazil and it's not available there
so how did you see it
um and they'll get defensive sometimes
and weird about I don't really do that
too much but uh you know I thought it
was amusing for a minute but but yeah
it's it's really like the most somehow
the most entitled people I guess it's
not surprising because they feel
entitled to just steal the movie then
they also feel entitled they're they're
like they've been wronged if it's not
like a you know a masterpiece and they
feel entitled to go out and kind of pull
the rating down
and how long ago was this that this
happened uh the last one was with a
movie that came out in
2019 so it's happened to you and Sophia
more than once we've definitely had
where where as soon as it's uh that was
the worst the worst case
um but we've definitely had other cases
in IMDb where
um
as soon as it's you know you start
seeing as soon as it goes up on the
torrent sites you start seeing all those
low uh ratings
what was your reaction to the experience
aside from attempting to maybe try to
poke back but then realized it was a
waste of time
yeah I mean it's a frustrating
experience because people do rely on it
for deciding whether to watch the movie
or not and I did at one point you know
years ago I did email IMDb and I said
look the movie's not out in these
countries like why are you allowing
ratings in countries where the movie has
not been released like these people
clearly have not seen it
um and they just say oh it balances out
you know they have some stock answer
anytime you complain about ratings there
they have some stock answer that they're
like it'll all bounce out don't worry we
wait everything it's all it's all fine
has this happened with all of your
movies uh I think all the ones that have
gotten wide released pretty much this
has happened with
um the ratings have have you know a
number of different types of issues it's
not just the piracy issue there are
um what I suspect I mean I can't prove
this but what I suspect are
Bots basically people pay I know I know
for a fact that many people pay for Bots
to get a certain number of ratings in
their movies and that's kind of a
a secret standard practice for a lot of
uh a lot of films including Studio films
and what happens with the Bots is that
they will go and rate you know let's say
I hire them to rate my movie in nine and
ten they go and do that but those bots
in order to not look suspicious they go
and read other random movies random
ratings including low ratings so that it
looks like they're giving a wide range
of reading so we've had movies before
they're even out that have not even come
out or they're on the festival circuit
that get a thousand you know like one
star ratings and I'm like who who is you
know who are these thousand people it's
certainly not people a thousand people
haven't even seen it at a festival and
suddenly there's you know a thousand
ratings on this that are one star so
um there's not really accountability in
the system and we can see patterns of it
you know based on we know the movie's
not out yet it shouldn't be shouldn't be
ratings for it what do you think about
independent filmmakers being judged
solely based on their IMDb rating
I mean I think any kind of rating like
that is unfortunate because it's not
it's not a
a scale of whether you know you or I
might like the movie it's like who who
are these random people who are deciding
to make this rating and I think it's
more important to understand that
certain movies are for certain people so
not every movie is for every person and
you know we see a lot of trolling on on
IMDb where it's like a movie's made for
like young girls and you see
there's like a wave of negative
responses from like you know
young men or older men who are basically
just trying to pull that movie down it's
like this movie is not for you you're
not really supposed to like it doesn't
matter if you like this that's not that
shouldn't be a way of assessing whether
the movie is successful or meaningful
um so it's a little bit frustrating
because I would love to see a system
where it's more like associated with how
how would we predict you would feel
about the movie if you watched it and um
I do use letterbox quite a lot I don't
really I don't rate movies on it but I
do like letterbox because I can see
um specifically how do my friends rate
them I don't care about you know
strangers but I can see oh my friend you
know really like this movie or my friend
really disliked this movie and I know
based on you know my relationship with
that person if they liked it maybe you
know it's something that I might like or
if they disliked it maybe it's something
I would dislike and I wouldn't
necessarily not watch it you know solely
based on that but it's a much better
sense of like what is your peer group
and how to how does that look than just
like a generic number
and with these Bots are they actually
leaving Long comments or they're just
basically giving it one star it's
usually just uh just a rating but there
are you can pay for reviews I've seen
people I've known people who paid for
reviews and with the paying for reviews
they're I think there are somewhere you
can write the reviews and send them to
them and they will they just post them
uh but there are some that kind of
generate pretty generic reviews and if
you go and browse on IMDb you can start
if you start seeing kind of weird
reviews you're like why is this written
like so strangely and generically you
can find and I you know I don't want
IMDb to to say I'm slandering them but I
think all this is pretty visible on the
on the uh on the outside I think you can
see you know where where there are fake
things happening there I think they know
about it and they
tolerated to a certain degree or they
don't have the resources to deal with it
I mean it's a complex problem to solve
to eliminate like all these Bots how do
you identify what a bot is versus you
know what a person is yeah very true
yeah and if you said they're going to
other account if they're leaving you
know it's be very hard to decipher if
you're seeing a trail of them on the
Internet leaving various reviews and it
happens on other platforms as well In
fairness to IMDb right yeah and it is it
is difficult to handle if a movie is
rated 5 out of 10 on IMDb will you still
watch it yeah I don't really judge uh
the scores very much I mean some of my
favorite movies I I kind of always when
we're picking movies out I always think
about like what is my favorite movie
what is the movie I love the most and
then I go look at the IMDb score and
it's like a you know 4.7 or or the
reviews are mostly negative or Rotten
Tomatoes score of you know 60 or
something like that I realize like the
things that connect with me most in
movies aren't necessarily what is gonna
play well in a general audience score
and movies that are nine you know movies
that are nine or 9.5 or Best Picture
winners I think are terrible movies I
think they're awful so um you know I
might look at it to get a sense of like
it gives me some information it says
okay what is it kind of a general
audience think about this but that
doesn't necessarily speak so much to
what my my interest will be and again
letterbox is a little bit more uh
targeted because I can see what specific
people say about it I can I can uh have
a breakdown of like who is saying what
rather than IMDb where it's just a
number
can you think of what some of the
highest rated Independent films are
uh Independent films
um you know I don't pay that it's hard
because I don't pay that much attention
to the scores but I think
um
some of the highest rated ones you know
often are ones where they just have a a
niche audience and that Niche audience
is really passionate about it uh but
they haven't you know if they haven't
fallen prey to the the Bots or other
things like that
um I'm trying to think of a really good
example and I nothing comes to mind uh
Rotten Tomatoes I mean lots lots of
movies have high Rotten Tomatoes scores
because partly because they don't have
that many reviews or sometimes they're
good good Independent films have high
scores
um there's been a trend I think in
Rotten Tomatoes where reviewers are a
lot nicer now because the reviewers are
a lot more uh there's a broader base of
reviewers who are now included in Rotten
Tomatoes and I think those reviewers are
a lot more friendly and they feel like
they owe something to the movies that
are beat they're being sent screeners
and all kinds of things whereas if you
go back and you look at a movie that
came out 30 years ago or 40 years ago
and you look at the Rotten Tomatoes
rating I think it's it's often much much
lower than it would be if it had come
out now
um
so yeah I can't think of any specific
Independence that I again I don't pay
very close attention but I think you
have to take it in the context of the
time who's rating it you know what what
do the ratings look like and Rotten
Tomatoes
um also a high rating doesn't mean
everybody loved the movie it means
everybody thought the movie was you know
at least okay
so sometimes there are movies that that
nobody really loves but everybody is
kind of like yeah it's fine and those
have very high Tomato scores because
nobody really said that it's a terrible
movie
and on letterbox do movies also get
downloaded uh they they people
definitely write you know negative
things or give low scores uh on
letterbox
um but again same way I don't take the
score too seriously and I'm more
interested in like what do my friends
say about it if I'm if I'm you know
curious about a movie what did my
friends review say and I'll read The
Strangers reviews as well and you can
get a sense of whether a person's like
this is the worst movie ever it's
terrible I hate it um and those kind of
reviews are like I wish they would just
kind of expunge all the I would give it
no stars if I could or it's you know
it's not a meaningful
um assessment of a movie sure I think
back to Roger you know from Cisco and
Ebert and just especially he's one book
um I hated hated hated this movie and if
you read
just I mean it's entertaining it doesn't
mean it's going to stop me from wanting
to see the film I actually sometimes
want to see it more when I hear people
complain about a film because I want to
know I do the same with Amazon reviews
on books or whatever like really they
thought this now it makes me actually
want to read it even more so sometimes
it can actually work in your favor but
yeah I mean I think Uber is is uh I mean
is it you know brilliant sure viewer no
doubt but uh he had a really interesting
bias especially in his early career
against horror movies so I so I'm really
interested in horror films and so I love
reading like the Roger Ebert reviews of
horror films because they're all like
even the most beloved horror films that
I I think are great that generally now
people have come to think are great he's
like this is just trash it has no ideas
it's you know awful I mean he writes the
most scathing scathing reviews of all
these movies like you know
zero Stars you know all thumbs down
everything
um and I think you know as he got older
he started to reassess like if he he
changed his way of assessing some of
those films and I think people who are
critics at that time felt like they had
to conform with some of the Norms of the
time and horror movies were very uh they
were inherently kind of trashy they were
inherently believed to be trashy so
people were very reluctant to give them
positive reviews because it kind of
almost reflected badly on the critic
whereas now horror movies are much more
respected I mean still there are many
people who don't respect horror movies
at all but they're much more respected
and they're much more they're considered
a more acceptable kind of mainstream
idea and so you see a really different
approach to criticism
um than you know what was done in the
past that's an interesting take because
I think did he apologize to some actress
was it Tippy hendren or somebody oh I
don't know which but there was somebody
that he said you know what any review or
or negative thing that I put about her I
apologize or whatever yeah he's
definitely a retracted stuff or
rethought you know reviews and I think
that's that's a that's something nothing
wrong with that that's not that doesn't
mean you're a you know bad person or you
did something wrong I think it's totally
it's totally respectable to change your
mind about something or have new context
or to understand something differently
um so yeah I mean I think that's that's
the times have changed I'd say